[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi
30 septembre bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une émission durant
laquelle nous allons revenir sur
l'actualité de la semaine voici lé titre
le plus grand salon de l'automobile du
monde où vous serez ouvre ses portes ce
week-end à paris quelles sont les
nouveautés du salon alors que vous savez
de nombreuses marques sont basés dans
les yvelines où le prix de richie s'est
rendu sur place en avant première arnaud
richard députée u10 de la 7e
circonscription des yvelines sera notre
invité fil rouge pour cette émission
avec lui nous évoquerons notamment
l'accueil des migrants en france et en
ile de france et doit remettre un
rapport notamment sur le sujet le 5
octobre prochain et dans le reste de
l'actualité bien sûr les explications
sur la hausse importante de la taxe
foncière dans les yvelines ou encore la
nouvelle maison de l'étudiant qui a été
inauguré officiellement à lui vs cure
mais on ouvre ce journal aux états unis
avec la plus grande compétition de golf
au monde la ryder cup cette compétition
qui voit s'opposer les meilleurs
golfeurs américains et les meilleurs
golfeurs européens
c'est disputera dans deux ans au golf
national de saint-quentin miquel et demi
d'euros couvre justement l'événement
cette année il nous fait part de ses
premières impressions en compagnie de
paul armitage et le directeur du golf
national
nous savons que paul armitage au golf
azal times du minnesota pour la 40e
édition de la ryder cup alors comment
vous sentez vous dans cette ryder cup
pool hermitage ça vous n'êtes pas trop
dépaysé par rapport à la france non pas
du tout pas du tout déjà je suis anglo
saxons donc j'arrive à communiquer bien
avec avec les personnes autour de nous
par contre je me sens comme un enfant
dans un dans un magasin de bonbons je
suis je suis très heureux et très excité
et vrai j'ai envie de manger tous les
bonbons et au niveau organisation
vraiment il ya rien à redire sur cette
ryder cup franchement franchement non là
il nous en fait un spectacle ils nous
font un spectacle formidable
avec ce qu'on appelle un style jean
plane la construction et l'organisation
de tous qui est absolument formidable un
des avantages qu'ils ont ici par contre
c'est ce qu'ils ont beaucoup de beaucoup
d espace le golf est propriétaire de
nombreux champs autour donc ils peuvent
garer les gens en tout près ils peuvent
mettre des énormes structures que l'on
voit ici à côté du golfe est juste à
côté du practice là où on se trouve où
le petit gris ou le départ du 1 c'est
incroyable il ya beaucoup de monde
également on voit des personnes
déguisées en oncle savons où on voit des
européens également il ya vraiment
énormément de monde assure ce golf oui
tout à fait et c'est intéressant si vous
dites parce que je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup d'européens qui sont déplacés
peut-être plus d'européens qui se
déplacent ici que des américains qui se
déplacent lorsque c'est en europe à
gleneagles en écosse il ya deux ans ou
peut-être en verra dans deux ans chez
nous mais il ya énormément de monde ils
ont de bonnes idées là aussi de comment
comment remplir les éléments
s'étaient ouverts au public le week-end
dernier même sans avoir quoi que ce soit
comme tournoi sur le site mais pour
donner un peu d'ambiance à des gens qui
n'avaient pas des billets bien sûr
commercialement ouvrir les merchandizing
mais on tourne à peu près à 40 45 mille
personnes par jour en spectateur à ça il
faut rajouter des cinq à dix mille
personnes qui travaillent c'est un petit
mot peut-être pour le golf national qui
équivaut regardant son oui oui bah vous
manqués mais bon on est bien ici quand
même à bientôt merci paul merci
merci à vous michael la 41e édition de
la ryder cup se déroule aux états unis
jusqu'au 2 octobre et vous pourrez
retrouver d'ailleurs une émission
spéciale ryder cup lundi 3 octobre sur
l'antenne de tv fil à partir de 18h45
c'est une tradition tous les deux ans le
début de l'automne est marquée par
l'ouverture du mondial de l'auto à paris
dès ce week-end et jusqu'au 16 octobre
précisément le public pourra admirer les
nouveautés des constructeurs les
constructeurs pour la plupart présents
dans le département des yvelines est
wilfrid richie est allé à leur rencontre
regardée
[Musique]
peugeot citroën renault nissan mercedes
ou encore fiat la plupart des nouveautés
présentées au mondial de l'automobile à
paris son nez dans les centres de
recherche et les usines yvelinoise la
concept car de citroën la ces
expériences a ainsi été conçue dans les
locaux de psa à vélizy avec l'appui
d'une pme basée à guyancourt une
implantation qui n'a rien à voir avec le
hasard on est nous dans un business qui
est un vrai business géographie
notre activité et l'activité de nos
concurrents on est tous dans un rayon de
5 km autour des constructeurs
automobiles que son psa et renault il ya
deux grands constructeurs en france
renault et psa et tout le monde dans le
design travail autour des constructeurs
autre vedette de ce salon avoir vu en
partie le jour dans le département la
trésor de renault prototype dévoilé en
première mondiale par carlos ghosn pdg
de la marque au losange
le concept car que vous allez découvrir
maintenant étant quelque chose là qu'on
fasse de notre prochain chapitre qui
s'annonce
tout aussi passionnant
un concept qui préfigure le fils de
nouveaux modèles dans l'écran magnifique
lui gt électrique des prototypes qui ne
manqueront pas d'attirer les visiteurs
sur les stands et qui pourrait même les
inciter à acheter des véhicules de la
marque les nouveautés ne manquent pas
cette année de renault avec sa clio iv
restylée à peugeot et sa deuxième
version de la 3008 en passant par
citroën et sa toute nouvelle c3 citroën
qui comme ses concurrents s'est fixé des
objectifs en termes de ventes sur cette
quinzaine c'est une nouveauté d'ailleurs
pour citroën puisque c'était pas le cas
il ya deux ans cette année on a pour
citroën et pur dsd vendeurs qui sont
présents sur le stand et qui sont là qui
attendent les clients pour faire de très
belles offres et vendre
le plus de voitures possible on peut
commander sa voiture sur mondial aura
touché vous pouvez la commander vous
pouvez aussi la réserve est allé la
chercher aussi empreint de vendre
le salon est ouvert jusqu'au 16 octobre
et pour le grand public ce sera aussi
l'occasion de découvrir les dernières
technologies au service du confort et
cette tendance qui se confirme faire de
votre voiture le prolongement de votre
smartphone entre caméra embarquée et
échanges de données avec les autres
utilisateurs
l'électrique reste aussi une valeur sûre
mercedes dont le siège est d'ailleurs
basé à montigny le bretonneux elle vient
de dévoiler x y ou son nouveau projet
100% électrique
on passe maintenant à l'actualité de la
semaine avec notre invité fil rouge
arnaud richard députée udi de la 7e
circonscription des yvelines bonsoir
bonsoir nicolas et l'actualité de la
semaine est forcément politique avec la
primaire de la droite qui approche et
des nouvelles révélations cette semaine
autour de la sphère bygmalion qui
embarrasse nicolas sarkozy ou encore les
autres révélations de patrick buisson
sur les précédentes campagnes
présidentielles le ton de cette campagne
est pour l'instant plutôt assez dure
entre les différents candidats que ce
soit à travers la presse à travers des
meetings interposés est ce que ça vous
rend forte dans le choix qu'a fait lui
dit de ne pas participer à cette
primaire est ce que vous dites ouf on
n'y est pas alors lui dit a fait le
choix de ne pas avoir candidat dans
cette primaire c'était le choix que nous
avons fait dans de notre congrès du 15
mars après les parties se donnent le
choix de prendre des positions dans les
semaines à venir c'est vrai que le ton
est un peu particulier mais non
l'ampleur de l'enjeu est énorme tout le
monde imagine que celle ou celui qui
gagnera la primaire sera le prochain
président de la république douce
effectivement à une quarantaine de jours
du premier tour le ton est donné et
j'espère qu'enfin on va pouvoir parler
des propositions que les candidats de la
droite pour eux du centre souhaite
mettre sur la table vous vous intéressez
personnellement est ce que lui d y aussi
s'intéresse à cette campagne quel est
votre regard votre tactique est ce que
vous allez voir en fonction du vainqueur
si vous vous positionnez ou pas dans
cette présidentielle je crois pas que ce
soit une histoire de tactique je crois
que l'enjeu pour la droite et le centre
est
arrivé à mettre cette majorité dehors et
a changé de président de la république
pour trouver des voies et moyens pour
amener le pays vers l'avenir peu un sens
ça c'est pas une histoire de tactique
c'est une histoire d'orientation de
choix de famille politique c'est pas
être peu importe le vainqueur je crois
surtout il faut que nos positions que
sur l'europe sur la laïcité sur
l'humanisme sur l'entreprise puisse
passer auprès de celle ou celui qui
gagnera cette prime aujourd'hui on
connaît les valeurs de l'udf
proeuropéenne pro humaniste un peu un
peu comme le modem est est ce que ces
valeurs là un candidat par exemple comme
nicolas sarkozy les partages imaginons
le 27 novembre il est élu il est choisi
candidat pour la présidentielle à droite
et est ce que lui dit va se rallier à
nicolas sarkozy chaque élection chaque
jour sa peine faisant le premier tour
voyons le deuxième tour et pour
l'instant il faut faire campagne donc il
faut que celles et ceux qui veulent se
mobiliser pour cette primaire qui est un
moment important pour la vie politique
française le fasse autour des
propositions qui sont en présence et
qu'ils vont être mis bientôt dans le
débat public qu'est ce qui lie qu'est ce
qui est important pour lui dit justement
dans cette campagne c'est quoi ce sont
les actualités européenne enfin les
sujets le sujet de l'europe a le sujet
de l'europe qui est souvent très mise à
mal dans les campagnes même les
campagnes européennes pour tout vous
dire et souvent dans les campagnes
nationales le sujet de la dette est un
sujet très important la dette je reviens
d'allemagne nos collègues allemands nous
disait qu' il faut vraiment qu'on arrive
à mettre le sujet de la dette publique
française dans le débat de la primaire
une présidentielle europe dette les deux
priorités pour vous en tout cas l'emploi
mais ça c'est notre adn à tous les
candidats et van rompuy l'environnement
c'est l'adn de jean louis borloo et lui
dit alors dans les huit candidats en
lice pour cette primaire qu'elle sait
qu'elle est celui selon vous qui est qui
qui parle le plus de ces sujets là qui
vous correspond le plus il ya beaucoup
de vos parlementaires qu'ils soient au
sénat ou à l'assemblée nationale qui ont
parrainé alain juppé le favori actuel
des sondages beaucoup soyons clairs il
va t elle si sur cet argumentaire copie
sans compter les députés européens vous
avez 18 collègues qui ont arrêté un hp
et donc ça veut dire qu'il reste
grande masse de messages en a eu le plus
au sein de vue pour l'instant c'est un
bouquet ma vie plus au sein dudit tout à
fait ce qui veut dire que c'est celui
qui correspondent plus à vos abobo non
c'est celui qui correspond le plus aux
valeurs de ceux qui nous ont rejoints et
vous à titre personnel moi à titre
personnel braille failli donner mon
parrainage comme valérie d'ailleurs
pécresse pour nathalie kosciusko morizet
même si on n'a pas toujours été très
très long n'est pas proche avec valérie
mais avec nathalie mai mais parce que je
trouve qu'elle a des choses à apporter
dans le débat et c'est bien que nathalie
une femme soit présente sur la tribune
des primaires on va évoquer avec vous
maintenant un autre sujet qui s'est
immiscé dans cette campagne dans
l'actualité ces derniers jours l'accueil
des migrants avec notamment le
démantèlement annoncé du camp de calais
ou de campement parisien dans les
yvelines la préfecture a annoncé qu'elle
allait accueillir plusieurs dizaines de
personnes sur de nouveaux sites un sujet
que vous connaissez bien vous arnaud
richard puisque vous êtes l'auteur d'un
rapport qui évoque ce sujet précisément
mais avant de vous donner la parole les
précisions sur le contexte local avec
flore imparfait
des migrants accueillis dans les
yvelines la décision a été confirmée par
le préfet les maires du canton du
chesnay incluant bougival la celle saint
cloud rocancourt et louveciennes ont
appris la nouvelle vendredi matin ils
ont tenu une conférence de presse pour
exprimer leur position face à ce plan
d'accueil art concours une centaine de
migrants sera accueilli pour une période
maximale de deux mois sur le site de
l'inria on est mis devant le fait
accompli et il est évident que
rocancourt déjà 100 migrants dans une
commune de 3200 habitants ça représente
4% de la population et on estime que
c'est déjà beaucoup et qui sera
difficile de cohabiter de son côté
l'ancien hébergera de façon pérenne 100
à 200 personnes une situation
problématique pour la commune en effet
de l'amiante aurait été détectée sur le
site situé lui même proche d'une
discothèque en plus de cela un projet
d'aménagement avec des entreprises
devrait voir le jour sur ce site de
ville vers un lieu inadapté pour
recevoir autant de personnes selon le
maire tu sais pour reproduire ce qui
s'est passé à calais ça j'y suis
totalement enfin dans la danse dans
l'esprit j'y suis totalement opposé en
tout cas je suis fermement opposé à
l'installation d'un camp fans à caen
deux migrants sur le site de villevayre
que ce soit 10 que ce soit sans les
problèmes de sécurité sont les mêmes
les deux maires opposés à ces
implantations obtenu du préfet qu'un
groupe de travail de concertation soit
mise en place le plan d'accueil
nécessite 400 places sur l'ensemble des
yvelines nous avons jusqu'à je dirais
fin octobre pour éventuellement trouver
des solutions d'accueil de ces personnes
s'ils ne trouvent pas la solution on
nous imposerait la solution de lucian
les migrants pourraient arriver sur le
camp provisoire de l'inria au concours
dans les jours qui viennent concernant
l'ancien l'échéance est prévue fin
octobre début novembre du côté de la
population la colère gronde une pétition
a été lancée par la ville de
louveciennes celle de rocancourt a déjà
obtenu 1300 signatures en quelques jours
alors quelques précisions d'abord sur le
sujet puisque les actualités circule
beaucoup les informations changent
beaucoup sur le sujet alors il ya une
réflexion qui est menée par la
préfecture pour trouver des nouveaux
sites sur les yvelines depuis juin 2015
un peu plus de 400 personnes ont été
accueillies sur le département objectif
100 accueillera 400 en plus arnaud
richard il ya on le voit dans le sujet
une vraie crispation sur de tels sujets
sur un tel sujet surtout de la part des
élus de droite est ce que ça vous étonne
ou est ce que vous comprenez cette
inquiétude dans l'inquiétude et les
grandes vis-à-vis de la situation
internationale d'abord parce que c'est
une crise qui ne fait que commencer
fruit de guerre sur le continent
africain et d'une évolution
démographique sur le continent africain
donc c'est une crise qui va durer et
nous nous sommes qu'au commencement
après il faut que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités et moi je ne suis pas du
genre à raconter n'importe quoi sur ces
sujets difficiles nous avons une
responsabilité par rapport à des
engagements que nous avons pris après la
deuxième guerre mondiale la convention
de genève que la plupart des pays au
monde signées de recueillir les
personnes qui sont en état de fragilité
ou face à une guerre dans leur pays ces
personnes sont arrivées en europe la
plupart en allemagne il faut être très
clair je ne sais pas si nous
les français ont conscience du nombre de
demandeurs d'asile en lorgnant giles
c'est un million de personnes rien
millions de personnes en allemagne entre
quelques dizaines de millions d'entre 30
mille en france
six étaient quarante mille ça n'a rien à
voir rien à voir alors c'est vrai que
les chiffres sont bien supérieurs à ce
qu'on a connu j'ai le tableau là ces
dernières années nous étions à 23 23
mille demandeurs d'asile en 2007 et nous
allons être en 2015 a à peu près 68 ce
gap est important c'est indéniable mais
surtout il ya une concentration de ces
demandeurs d'asile en ile de france à
paris en particulier mais en ile de
france aussi est dans le mur ces deux
régions de france prennent à peu près
60% de l'ensemble des demandeurs d'asile
donc ce qu'a fait le gouvernement c'est
d'essayer desserrer l'étau d'envoyer des
demandeurs d'asile aux quatre coins de
la france il faut appeler un chat ce que
vous nous proposez aussi dont il n'y a
pas d'autre solution que ça parce que
j'étais l'autre jour à côté de deux vice
présidents de départements de la région
est et puis notre site annie d'occitanie
à 12 départements
si on leur envoie venant d'île de france
et venant du nord mille demandeurs
d'asile s'affaissant par département
somme toute c'est pas grand chose à dire
sur quels critères se cette répartition
des mavs à l'arrêt les paraphes hors
cessions elles selon la démographie les
critères non oui et je fais un peu sur
la démographie
c'est à peu près un millier un millier
sur sur l'évacuation de calais donc sur
lequel le france ne sera pas touchée
après nous avons la situation locale sur
lequel beaucoup d'associations font de
boulot dans les yvelines nous avons pu
effectivement vous l'avais dit dans
votre reportage 400 personnes je sois à
bonnel à versailles à masi et attribue
ça se passe de manière plus ou moins
satisfaisants alors selon la préfecture
en tout cas ça se passe plutôt bien pas
de pas de faits majeurs de délinquance
notamment une crainte de la part des
minimes et je veux dire il comme pour
l'asim être à la place de la population
je pense à musique est un village de
2000 habitants où le maire a dû être
prévenu une semaine avant il y avait un
prêt jaune projet de maison de retraite
qui ne fonctionnait pas qu'ils avaient
pas trouvé son offre or ça s'est passé
pas satisfaisant joue la corde tout d'un
coup ils se retrouvent à midi avec une
centaine de migrants quel est le premier
en fait c'est le fond c'est le fait que
des migrants arrivent sur ces
territoires là ou alors des demandeurs
d'asile d'ailleurs ou alors c'est la
forme le fait que ce soit fait dans la
précipitation ces deux choses
différentes si c'est la précipitation
j'ai du mal à croire que tous les élus
qui se sont exprimés serait prêt à
accepter la chose si le préfet le leur
demander longtemps la vence
manifestement on manque d'outils de
concertation mais en manque surtout
d'accompagnement on met des sommes
importantes sur ces sujets moi je suis
pas totalement satisfait de la qualité
de l'accompagnement voilà parce que les
demandeurs d'asile c'est un public
difficile il faut les accompagner soit
pour avoir leur demande d'asile et
pourraient être réfugiés soit pour ne
pas la voir et ça veut dire est débouté
et être éloigné de la france
potentiellement fin octobre début
novembre on aura 800 migrants sur le
département des yvelines vous parliez de
chiffre tout à l'heure et ce que 800
migrants sur un département comme celui
des yvelines s'est s'est beaucoup
finalement est ce qu'il ya une seule
année par konami la réserve elle trois
millions d'habitants voilà ce qu'il ya
des raisons d'être inquiet vraiment ces
personnes qui comme vous le disions ce
qu'il faut pas en vouloir aux gens qui
sont épiés c'est pas c'est pas du
racisme
ou du rejet de l'autre c'est juste que
d'abord on écoute ça ne tourne pas
habitué à avoir des soudanais des
afghans des erythréens voilà c'est un
public un peu nouveau dans certains
territoires et puis l'accompagnement est
peut-être pas suffisant les moyens qui
sont donnés par l'état même si l'état il
faut le dire a fait des efforts mais vu
le début de la crise je leur dis bien il
faut des moyens supplémentaires il faut
des moyens supplémentaires les associe
cols que ce soit toutes les associations
caritatives la croix rouge qui fait un
travail remarquable
il faut surtout nos concitoyens
comprennent qu on est au début d'une
crise que c'est une crise qu'elle est
partie face à une guerre voilà c'est pas
de l'immigration ce sont des gens qui
sont en souffrance et face à une guerre
dans leur pays vous parliez des moyens
vous proposer des solutions dans ce
rapport vous allez remettre mercredi à
claude bartolone le président de
l'assemblée nationale et notamment faire
appel à la réserve de l'éducation
nationale alors est-ce que c'est nous
avons adressé un fonds connais la
réserve militer voilà tout à fait la
réserve bien sûr nationale qui a été
créée par le gouvernement il ya quelques
quelques mois on a un problème c'est que
celles et ceux qui vont avoir le statut
de réfugié parle évidemment pas très
bien français et le c'est à partir du
moment où ils ont le statut de réfugié
qu'on commence officiellement leur
donner des cours de français moi je
pense que si on pouvait mobiliser la
réserve toutes les associations qui font
un travail formidable pour
l'alphabétisation et pour
l'apprentissage du français ça serait
une bonne chose après vu le niveau
commence à prendre le nombre de migrants
en france et qu'en cette ère sombre et
réserve on connaît le nom de personnes
qui sont malheureusement ça n'a pas été
un très très grand succès de la part de
l etat c'est un peu le problème ça a été
un peu gérer comme pour tout ce qui
concerne l'éducation nationale du sang
argonnaise mais bon mais après je pense
qu'il faut mobiliser l'armée part
que ce soit bien encadré on dirait c'est
pas le rôle de l'armée mais c'est pas
drôle l'armée non plus d'exercer la
sécurité du territoire avec sentinelle
autant larmes il a très bien fait et
puis je pense qu'il faut aussi assumer
les quotas par région parce qu'il faut
que chacun prenne sa part il n'y a pas
de raison qui est que l'île de france et
le nord de la france qui prennent 60%
des migrants dans notre pays il faut que
chacun s'y colle parce que c'est un
exercice difficile et qu'il faut toutes
les collectivités puissent y coller et
que l'état ça va peut-être la transition
avec deux prochains points donne des
moyens aucune activité que ce soit comme
une interview au département pour
exercer ses missions somme toute
nouvelle un ccs dans un département
rural
il n'est pas habitué à gérer les
politiques migratoires évidemment vous
le disiez parfaite transition avec une
autre actualité cette semaine une hausse
importante + 66 % c'est l'augmentation
de la taxe foncière dans les yvelines un
record en france pour 2016 alors
pourquoi une telle augmentation
les explications
le chiffre est impressionnant plus 66%
aucun département français ne fait mieux
la hausse de la taxe foncière dans les
yvelines bat des records cette année de
cette vague là 58 % en 2015 à 12,58 % en
2016 soit une hausse en moyenne par
contribuable 225 euros et forcément la
nouvelle passe mal auprès des intéressés
toujours des os que ce soit pour les
impôts pour tout augmente
malheureusement le pouvoir d'achat
n'augmente pas et voilà ça fait beaucoup
et
il a marre je pense que à l'heure
actuelle ça fait mal au porte-monnaie
pour tous les français peut-être plus
plus encore pour les yvelinois
matraquage tout simplement 66% c'est du
matraquage je peux comprendre qu'ils
aient des charges mais faut pas exagérer
quoi mise en cause le département charge
de l'impôt se défend évoque notamment
une hausse des dépenses sociales type
rsa mais accus surtout l'état et la
baisse des dotations une baisse qui
atteint cette année 38 millions d'euros
pour le département des yvelines même
mes collègues dans les autres
départements ne croyait pas que l'état
nous avait repris 90% de sa dotation
tous me disent c'est impossible puisque
dans les autres départements de l'ain a
pris 30 ou 40% il ya les hybrides ont
été particulièrement puni pour une
raison très simple elles dépensent peu
elles sont économes des deniers publics
et elles ont une fiscalité faible et
quasiment pas de tête dans le
gouvernement actuel ça s'appelle de la
mauvaise gestion en ile-de-france eu
d'autres départements ont connu
également une hausse importante de leur
taxe foncière en 2016 c'est le cas par
exemple du voisin essonniens + 29 % pour
un taux d'imposition cette fois-ci de
16,37 % arnaud richard en tant que
député des yvelines c'est un sujet qui
doit forcément vous intriguer vous
intéressez vous pensez quoi de
l'argument du département il son
président qu'on a vu à l'instant pierre
bédier qui dit en gros vulgairement on
n'a pas le choix l'état baisse des
moyens on a plus de charge donc il faut
bien qu'on augmente les impôts c'est un
peu la faute de l'état c'est un argument
c'est la réalité l'état a baissé de 90%
la dotation qu'il donnait aux yvelines
au département il ya un moment toutes
les politiques publiques fait
le département et dont les droits sont
très contents est ce qu ils veulent que
tout s'arrête ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième les débats le département
les yvelines comme les autres exercent
une mission pour l'état ce qu'on
appelait le rsa avec des lois qui sont
votées celle ci j'ai pas voté
rassurez-vous et qui sont mises en
oeuvre par les collectivités locales
donc l'état rembourse à un niveau tu es
et aujourd'hui ça coûte t + 3 + 4 plus
mais l'état baisse des dotations paille
angeles les tailles et les dotations
vous parliez de la dette c'est aussi un
moyen de réduire la dette en baissant
les dotations hui léger les guérites
allons parler des primaires tout à
l'heure les candidats de droite
prévoient tous un programme encore plus
important pour les cinq années à venir
est ce que vous êtes inquiet pour cette
dotation qui va j'aimerais jouer les
mandats et les démembrements de l'état
fasse autant d'efforts que les
collectivités ont fait céder les forces
et troisième années on n'a jamais vu
autant d'efforts lors c'est vrai que cet
effort c'est bien pour la gestion de la
dette ça c'est indéniable et vous le
dire mais pour autant ça une conséquence
est que les connaît les collectivités
locales communes collective et interco
ou départements sont obligés d'augmenter
les impôts aujourd'hui vous dites il
faut aller place l'état mais c'est fou
ce comme toujours sur les collectivités
locales est en train de trouver de
l'argent on va dire dans d'autres
domaines pas forcément les collectivités
il ya un moyen très simple messieurs je
suis pas certains qui que ce soit avec
orange y aller c'est de simplifier le
millefeuille intercommunale
vous dire moins de collectivités - 2 -
de brad monstre at on sera tous vous
pensez à la métropole du grand paris par
exemple - et qui pourrait être couplée
avec la région ile de france moi je
pense que les intercours va voir si ça
fonctionne dans l'année mais attention
parce que ici vous êtes à 50 ans niveau
et bien sûr il est à levante gagne
intercommunautés mais je ne sais jamais
quand je passe d'une ville à une autre
et en étendant cette intercours est
incertain deux fois je me dis que
on parlerait d'une nouvelle commune de
saint quentin voilà avec les maires
qu'ils resteraient les maires toutes les
deux toutes les villes qui la composent
on aurait beaucoup beaucoup baissent de
l'idée de cette réforme des
collectivités locales qui a voulu faire
l'état en particulier avec les régions
s'étaient baisser les dépenses liées aux
régions on voit bien que ça ne
fonctionne pas ça ne fonctionne pas
justement l'état et manuel valls a
annoncé hier que le gouvernement ne va
plus à partir du 1er janvier 2018 verser
une dotation globale de fonctionnement
aux régions mais une part de la tva sera
pour les régions vous pensez quoi de
cette idée présidents de région ont
trouvé que c'était une bonne idée c'est
un changement énorme c'est un changement
énorme puisque vous allez
avoir un budget des régions qui sera en
fonction de la consommation
voilà de la croissance donc c'est un
risque qu'une certaine manière que
prennent les présidents de région en
acceptant cette modification de manuel
valls ça va l'épouser surtout ça va les
pousser peut-être est un peu plus
mobiles sur les économies chine et ça
c'est intéressant mais après tout vous
oubliez pas un peu de chose c'est que
quand on baisse les collectivités des
dotations des collectivités d'abord elle
s'oublie de compter dans un pot c'est
pas satisfaisant mais les yvelines
avaient un taux très bas les 10000 ne
sont pas endettés et elles sont très
bien gérés puis 13 d'ailleurs le reste
inférieur à la plupart des départements
des suns qui est assez pour cent nous on
va être à dos pour cent c'était
insupportable pour les gens jouent
l'accord mais il faut bien comprendre
que c'est la suite de la baisse des
dotations et puis surtout les
collectivités locales sont le moteur de
la croissance c'est elle qui dépensent
de l'argent public pour vous redire de
la croissance et donc de l'emploi dans
notre pays et ça c'est une grosse erreur
qu'a fait le gouvernement on referme ce
journal avec de la culture et
l'exposition en cours des oeuvres de
l'artiste ben à la maison elsa triolet
aragon de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
l'artiste né suisse interroge les
visiteurs dans cette exposition et
notamment la vérité jusqu'au 27 novembre
pour plus de précision et découvrir les
oeuvres d'un ben provocateur qui
bouscule nos convictions consultez le
site internet de la maison elsa triolet
l'adresse s'affiche sur vos écrans
c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo merci
arnaud richard de nous avoir accompagnés
pendant cette demi heure je rappelle que
vous êtes député udi de la 7e
circonscription des yvelines est
notamment vice président de l'uwe dit
merci à vous également de nous avoir
suivis bon week-end à tous et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]